let's talk about what's going on with
Jordan Peterson man this is Jordan
Peterson Newsday daily wire the new
streaming service daily wire plus signed
Jordan Peterson to a multi-year deal
I was laughing all night so this news
came out uh basically during our show
yesterday and then when I found out I
started laughing I'm like this is
amazing yeah CNN plus couldn't last
three weeks they were supposed to
implode within a month and then even a
few days early they couldn't even fail
on time and watching there just collapse
then CNN had this announcement that like
their daytime host was like I'm quitting
I'm tired of being tired I don't want to
do this anymore and then daily wire is
expanding rapidly they're signing new
shows they're launching new shows
they're they're bringing in Dennis
Prager and Jordan Peterson in April they
had 600 000 subscribers now they have
890 000 subscribers and so it was just a
good day you know what I say
I'll say this earlier I'm not motivated
by money I'm not doing this because I
want to buy a Ferrari a Lambo and build
a mansion if that no I I would love
nothing more than to walk out of my Hut
into a field of fresh fruit and and farm
them and smile upon a grateful Universe
knowing that we have snapped out of
existence the corporate press and the
establishment garbage manipulative trash
I want to see the Liars called out I
want to see accountability from The
Establishment the daily wire is doing
that good for them we want to do that
too that's what I want to do every
single day so when I see the daily wire
pulling this off and I see CNN failing I
know that we are we are we are winning
it's a big turn in the time man that's a
that's a well like a extremely
established turn in the in the momentum
of if you want to call culture War like
the sense of the I mean they've they've
not only have they increased their
subscriber Base by like 20 30 in like
three months which was massive what was
it 600 000 to 900 something yeah that's
a 50 increase yeah yeah it's this is
really really well that's from one
documentary that's from Matt's I am
mostly as a woman that's a big part of
what that came from I think Gina Carano
of course the the terror on the Prairie
came out Gina's just a superstar right
now I mean she's a big part of the
momentum of that and deserves she's
notoriety as she's getting let's just do
some math real quick
twelve dollars per month
300 000 people
per month
it's like 1.7 million one
no it's it's it's 3.6 3.6 million per
month per month added on top of their
existing 600 000 so they're they're
hitting like I think I think the math is
10.6 million dollars per month
per month that's just in subscriptions
and that's not in Cloud accounting their
ad Revenue yeah man merchandise all that
stuff we got to get 300 employees 890
000 website you know but you know it's a
no ball rolling down hill they've been
doing this for seven eight years now
right so they're really really taking
off and uh man it just feels good man
you know sitting back and just seeing
their success it was really funny
because when the news broke I tweeted
out saying holy-ish and then I had these
Lefty journalists being like haha LOL
and laughing and I'm just like bro
you're like I'm the verge of being
unemployed what are you laughing about
you gonna go you're gonna go manage an
AMC like
what are you doing I got question now is
is Jordan an American citizen is he
going to get his American citizenship
after this like he's no he's Canadian I
don't know moving to Tennessee is he
going to go to Nashville he's probably
gonna or is he just keeping on with
keeping on I don't know I don't think he
has to be an American citizen do a
contract with no but does he get to
become one now I know he's fed up with
the Canadian government I mean he said
some really really he's one of just
introduce probably most accurate
harshest critics and justifiably so I
don't know if you know this but I'm
pretty sure you can just buy citizenship
like if you're rich at that point yeah
at that point and then you reach a
certain point where it makes sense to
renounce your citizenship for tax
purposes so I'm not sure where he falls
in that Spectrum on whether it makes
sense for him to become a citizen or to
renounce it well our Canadian taxes
higher or lower than the US
the income tax well now with the
increase
um I think our taxes might be higher I
think that at the higher level the
income tax is higher where Canada gets
you isn't necessarily the income tax
being hired in fact their corporate tax
uh for the larger corporations is lower
a lot of American companies like Burger
King was a famous one that moved to
being a Canadian company for the income
for the corporate tax purpose it's the
property taxes and the sales taxes it's
the it's the middle class that they're
hitting with the real taxes it's the
rich aren't the ones getting it also the
censorship tax which as is
unquantifiable I I it's kind of like uh
Einstein fleeing Nazi Germany before it
got bad like he saw the writing on the
wall was like you know well I mean
they've already I'm out they've also had
the not allowed to leave your Province
unless you're vaccinated tax that they
finally lifted earlier this month so um
I mean there's there's I mean if you're
talking about overall burden then it
goes beyond property taxes I saw a
picture from Canadian Airport and they
were like there's like four hour Waits
or six hour Waits at the airport and
it's just bags everything this huge line
and what are they what is he pudding
there's it's all Trudeau's fault what
he's putting these people through no I I
I just don't believe these people are
happy I just can't imagine they're happy
living in Canada yeah all the Canadian
people I know are like trying to come to
America why I'm not even kidding though
no and then it was funny I was hanging
out some Canadian friends and I was
ragging on Canada and they were getting
really mad
they were like you Americans are so
arrogant and I'm like you're trying so
hard to come here dude and they're like
that's still Americans are so arrogant
I'm like yeah and you want to be here
dude yeah
I agree the American arrogance was
grotesque because we really need to live
the ideals of the Constitution you know
it's not just it's not fair to like rest
on our Laurels because they work so hard
and intelligently to build that awesome
document and yeah I don't know I think
this country is going to implode like we
I didn't want to lead with the story but
I was talking about the dod earlier
saying they're going to keep performing
abortions regardless of whether the
states banned them right and I'm like
what happens if a woman
let's say you've got an active service
Personnel who lives in Texas where
they've just banned abortion
and she goes to a military base to get
an abortion and they have a civilian
doctor Contracting on the military base
to perform abortions yeah
I'm pretty sure I don't know about Texas
but I know there are laws that say that
if if you leave to pursue an abortion or
Aid in a bet someone getting an abortion
you can be criminally charged so I kind
of I'm feeling like in Texas
if if you live in a state then go to
Federal jurisdiction the federal
government's like don't worry you can't
be prosecuted for what we do here it's
legal when you come back they'll be like
no we have a law that says it doesn't
matter where you go to do it it's
illegal so I think about stuff like that
and I'm like yeah I think the US is kind
of about to explode you know but but you
know I say that just to provide a little
like juxtaposition to this good news
about the culture War because I don't
think it it means that the end is nigh
it just means we're in for a conflict a
revolution or something something what I
mean from the libertarian take what
we're hoping for is to move towards
peaceful decentralization and the first
step in that is and this is something
I'm working on on with you or the power
is local County and state level
nullification of bad laws higher up the
food chain that they don't like like the
NFA like the NFA uh you know Missouri
became a second amendment Sanctuary
State and I think New Hampshire just did
uh yes and what the ATF has already said
um and border patrol had to say this
with the immigration Sanctuary States
and I mean we know that they've had to
do this with all the Cannabis Sanctuary
states that without the local
authorities doing the like over 90 of
the heavy lifting and the actual
enforcement of these laws it's
functionally impossible for them to be
able to do it love to see it good that's
good well California started it
they wanted to do all the immigration
stuff and now we're going to see all the
two ways and the Cannabis stuff and the
immigration immigration and cannabis
okay great well now we're doing it for
everything that's right and and the
beauty of that is not just the the real
world implications of being able to
nullify bad state and federal policy at
the local level it also empowers the
citizen to know that their vote isn't
just cast into the into The Ether they
can take over their City their County
and eventually their state and get rid
of all the garbage that they don't have
to wear with all the stop at Capitol
Hill they can just stop it from being
effectively enforced where they live
where we are right now in Maryland there
are I think I think it's Three Counties
signed letters saying they wanted to
secede from Maryland to join West
Virginia it's never going to happen but
the county we're in actually declared a
two-way sanctuary
it doesn't mean a whole lot because the
state didn't yeah and so you still got
to get clearance from the state police
to make sure because the laws make no
sense here for guns but up in New
Hampshire the governor just signed a
bill that said they're no longer going
to cooperate with the feds and people
need to understand the feds don't have
the ability to police that country it's
not even close the states have to do it
for them so the the interesting thing is
when I'm reading about what was
happening with um
the the dod basically saying like we're
going to keep doing abortions regardless
of what the state law is I'm like
can federal agents be arrested for
breaking state laws do you know the
answer to that question uh I mean the
states can certainly arrest them for it
uh it's then going to have to work its
way through adjudication to see if
that's upheld the simple answer is well
obviously of course right if if an FBI
agent agent is caught like robbing a
bank yep it's of course it's going to
get charged but what I mean is if in
their duties as Federal officers they
break State law can the state arrest
them I think you have a duty to do it
because I mean the Union as it stands is
just a contract amongst the states the
only thing the only reason the federal
government even exists is because we're
letting it exist per our contract with
the Constitution well they they say that
Federal so this is an interesting thing
they say it's a supremacy clause things
like that the federal government's laws
supersede the state so if California
says weeds legal and the FEDS say no
it's not the feds can go into California
and enforce their law but what about the
inverse what if the feds say a cop
carrying a high-capacity magazine as
it's defined by space blue States they
say no no police aren't allowed to carry
those either now and the FEDS go in with
Glock 17s can the state say I don't care
who you are I don't care what you're
doing you broke the law I think you
that's what I can't find I think you
predicted the next one of the next big
contentious things to be handled at the
at the federal court level because
um that is likely to happen as the the
um the gap between what the federal
government's priorities and rules are
and what the states are priorities and
rules are that's going to lead to
conflict and it's not happening in
Washington DC it's not happening on
Federal Land it's happening on state
property on on in in state jurisdictions
that's who's likely to get arrested we
know the feds will arrest someone at the
state level uh you know in a Texas
second thanks for checking out this
segment from the timcast IRL podcast but
if you want to check out the full show
live tune in Monday through Friday at 8
pm and if you want more special access
content head over to timcast.com and
become a member your membership helps
sustain this company keep our
journalists employed makes this show
happen and you will get access to
exclusive members only segments of the
timcast IRL podcast and there's a
massive library to check out so again go
to timcast.com or tune in Monday through
Friday at 8pm and we'll see you all
there